joining me now from los angeles is nils
friends and a law professor at the
university of southern california he
worked on the legal framework to deal
with the haitian migrants trying to make
their way to the united states
thank you very much indeed for being
with us professor franson
as we're obviously seeing uh with this
case
it is by no means the first time that
we've seen
flotillas of boat people escaping
countries vietnam haiti cuba it's
happened a number of times
how do you think the europeans are
coping with this particular problem uh
compared with others in the past
well
the european the eu particularly in
italy were coping better a year ago when
the italian navy
and the italian government deployed the
massive rescue operation mari nostrum
but otherwise since that program ended
the eu has not been coping well
it's important to note however the
context in which this is all happening
right now
and that's syria that's one of the
primary drivers of this crisis
and this is the greatest refugee crisis
the world has faced since the end of
world war ii
so whose legal responsibility are these
people at sea and do we have a
responsibility to do more to stop them
drowning
well
i mean certainly uh under under the law
of sea under the search and refuge
convention when a ship encounters
another boat in distress there's a clear
legal obligation to render assistance um
there's a separate question as to
whether or not the eu or any member
state of the european union has an
affirmative duty to send rescue boats
out into for example libyan coastal
waters uh that's a gray area but we know
the boats are coming uh the eu has the
capability of rescuing and certainly
even if there's not a clear legal
obligation to go out and rescue uh
there's a moral and political
responsibility to do so
and on past president what is the most
effective way of bringing uh these sort
of human flows to an end
well
solving the solving the situation in
syria solving the situation in eritrea
and other sub-saharan countries that are
uh
have the conditions that are causing
people to flee that's obviously a long
long-term solution it doesn't deal with
what we're facing on a daily basis right
now
the eu should be
expanding the rescue operation and
creating other safe legal means by which
some people
from syria and other countries can
pursue uh legal uh pathways to to the eu
and other countries is there a legal
option to turn back boats as the
australians have done
uh there is not um what australia is
doing and what prime minister abbott is
calling for again is clearly illegal
under the refugee convention under the
convention against torture
we've seen pushbacks practiced by the
italians
in the mediterranean
the european court of human rights in in
2012 said in in no uncertain terms uh
that pushback practices uh uh are a
violation of the european uh convention
of human rights
and once you rescue people are they then
your responsibility
well international law says that once a
person is rescued that that person has
to be disembarked in a place of safety
and that's the gray area in
international law what is a place of
safety could it be tunisia
could it be eastern libya as opposed to
the the tripoli area which is controlled
by the new dawn
but clearly
once an individual is taken on board an
eu vessel whether it be an armed false
armed forces of malta a patrol boat or
an italian coast guard cutter that
person comes within the jurisdiction of
that particular eu state eu law applies
and that person has a right to pursue an
application for asylum or other forms of
protection within that eu state
professor franzen thank you very much
indeed for your advice